[Applause]
thank you very much
great to be in this wonderful state so
many friends so much success
and we love being here
and we're here actually today to discuss
the exciting progress that we've
achieved under the operation warp speed
our historic initiative to develop test
manufacture and deliver a vaccine in
record time and that's what it is in
record time
likewise therapeutically we are very
very advanced you're hearing about it
and you'll be hearing about it a lot
more in the next two weeks
we will achieve a victory over the virus
by unleashing america's scientific
genius which is what it is i'm
therefore proud to announce that this
morning
the moderna vaccine has officially
entered phase three already
and that's phase three clinical trials
the final stage
before approval there's never been
anything like this in terms of speed
nothing even close a second vaccine is
likely to enter phase three
in a matter of days under operation warp
speed
we've shaved years off of the time that
it takes to develop a vaccine
in some cases many years and we've done
it while maintaining the fda gold
standard for safety
this is the fastest a vaccine for a
novel
pathogen has ever gone it's never gone
like this
and if you look at where we are by
phase three we can say evergone by far
four additional promising candidates are
expected to enter final trials
in the coming weeks including the
novovax vaccine being developed
right here at this facility it's an
incredible facility
we're going to be making a tour in a
little while very
very complete tour with the folks that
run it and the people that operate
we've just completed a tour of
fujifilm's
innovation laboratories and that's going
to be uh done at
much much higher level in a few minutes
after i'm finished and i believe we'll
take a few questions too
which we're carrying out a crucial
bio-manufacturing process needed to make
the novavax vaccine
this production is made possible by my
administration's 1.6 billion dollar
award
to novavax as part of operation warp
speed it lets
us deliver the final product in a time
that never has been
achieved anywhere at any time for
anything like this
these same manufacturing processes
are being conducted on an even larger
scale
in college station texas today i'm proud
to announce that hhs has just signed a
265 million dollar contract with the
fujifilm texas
a m innovation center which is quite the
place
to dramatically expand their vaccine
manufacturing capacity
i want to thank fuji film ceo martin
mason
for welcoming us today and martin
worries martin
thank you thank you very much martin
it's really
wonderful to be with you under these
circumstances in particular with all the
progress that's being made
as well as novovac ceo stanley eric
stanley thank you very much thank you
very much for being here
thanks also to secretary alex azar who's
with us
senator tom tillis thank you very much
thank you tom stand up
tom good job you've done thank you very
much you really have
representatives richard hudson david
rouser
mark walker dan bishop and greg
murphy thank you all friends all
warriors
lieutenant governor dan forrest who i
hear is doing a great job where's dan
stand up dan
great job dan really good north carolina
house speaker tim moore
thank you tim great job and president
pro tem
of the north carolina state senate phil
berger thank you phil very much i
appreciate it
operation warp speed is funding a
historic portfolio of highly promising
vaccine candidates
in addition to our 1.6 billion dollar
investment in novavax
we've issued a 483 million dollar
contract with moderna
a 1.2 billion dollar contract with
astrazeneca
a 465 million dollar contract with
jansen and just last week a 1.95 billion
dollar agreement
with pfizer tremendous progress is being
made with all of those
great companies a groundbreaking
agreement with pfizer includes a
guarantee to deliver 100 million doses
shortly after the vaccine's approval
almost
immediately with the option to purchase
an additional 500 million thereafter
not only is operation warp speed
accelerating the development of a
vaccine
we're also directing a colossal
industrial mobilization to ensure its
rapid
delivery nothing's happened like this
since the end of world war
ii instead of the usual sequence of
vaccine development testing and trials
followed by production our strategy is
to conduct these
phases simultaneously so everything goes
at one time
we're not waiting and waiting and
waiting it's all going at one time
we have a system that has i think it's
unparalleled never been done before
but we suspect it's going to work and
work very well
we're mass producing all of the most
promising vaccine candidates in advance
so that on the day one that it's
approved
it'll be available to the american
people immediately and we'll probably
have a lot for
a lot of other people throughout the
world the world is suffering from
this china virus another dimension of
operation warp speed is our focus on
therapeutics to treat the virus
over 140 clinical trials are underway
and a number of effective therapies have
already been developed and widely
delivered
including rem deserver which is having a
tremendous impact you see that with
mortality rates and
other things statistically dexamethasone
convalescent plasma and antibody
treatments we have
numerous treatments right now that are
under study and i think over the next
couple of weeks we may actually have
some very positive
answers as to that on july 7th we
announced a 450 million dollar agreement
with regeneron to begin advanced
manufacturing of its antibody treatment
which is currently
in late stage clinical trials late stage
due to the medical advances we've
already achieved and our increased
knowledge and how to treat the virus the
mortality rate for patients over the age
of 18
is 85 percent lower than it was in april
think of that 85 percent
and is 25 percent lower than europe as a
whole
in the middle of april more than 22
percent of all deaths in the united
states were attributable to the china
virus
as the last week that number has dropped
down as of last week it's dropped down
to under
seven percent to decrease the turnaround
times for testing the
first two laboratories have been
approved to provide pooled
testing very important in other words
samples from multiple patients
are processed together they're pooled
now pool testing will reduce turnaround
times by
more than substantially more than 50
percent
last week our centers for medicare and
medicaid services began distributing
rapid point-of-care diagnostic test
instruments to all of the nursing homes
in the united states
focusing on the areas of greatest need
which is our
elderly and our nursing homes what we've
already sent
includes testing instruments to 635
nursing homes for
190 000 rapid point of care tests
it's a tremendous amount that's you'll
get your
response and answer from 5 to 15 minutes
over the next three weeks 1 700 nursing
homes will receive an additional eight
hundred thousand
point-of-care tests think of that the
united states has conducted over 52
million tests
that's more than all of europe put
together times two
nobody's even close and as countries go
it is as an example india
is up to 11 million tests we're going to
be very shortly at 55 million tests
india has 1.4 billion people
through our relentless efforts we've
completely rebuilt our stockpile
which the previous administration
depleted and did not refill
the cupboards were bare i say it often
in total
we've now distributed nearly 100 million
n95 masks
35 million surgical masks 15 million
facials and much much more
in addition to that ventilators the most
difficult
thing of all we are now building
thousands a month
and we're distributing we have all we
need in our country but to other
countries that are in desperate need
other countries are having a
tremendously difficult time with the
virus last week fema sent additional
personnel
protective equipment to over 15 000
nursing homes including 643
000 pairs of protective eyewear
7 million masks 34 million pairs of
gloves
and 6 million gowns it's a lot
over the weekend cases in florida texas
and arizona held steady and
are now heading down in arizona they're
heading very substantially down and
rapidly we've been
constant and in constant communication
with the states
and are surging them resources when
requested
they largely had what they needed but
anything they need we send them
immediately
we are totally full we have everything
we need we get it to the states
immediately we deal with the governors
the relationship with the governors has
been very good
these states are not out of the woods
but rigorous compliance with guidelines
should allow
them to turn the corner and very very
quickly
we are working with every governor and
health commissioner across the country
to bring a complete
individualized analysis to each state as
well as tailored
states are different my administration
is also closely monitoring the
surging caseload in latin america
which is now the region in the world
with the most active reported infections
by far
due to the relative scarcity of testing
in latin america however the region's
reported number of cases
is also likely to be dramatically
undercut or undercounted and i can say
that's probably true throughout the
entire world we report our cases most of
the world doesn't they either don't do
testing therefore they have very few
cases even though people are sick
or they just don't report and given the
reality of
what we just said we're focusing
aggressively on
the texas border and countries that we
think have to be watched very very
carefully because
you have some very very highly infected
countries
outside of our borders i've spoken with
governor
abbott terrific gentleman and i can
report that over three thousand three
hundred federal personnel
or on the ground in texas we've given
them a tremendous amount
amount of extra help including doctors
nurses
front line people we've supplied texas
with more than 2.5 million gloves
800 000 goggles 337 000
surgical gowns 1.8 million surgical
masks
1.36 million n95
respirators and half a million kn
90 masks beginning this week texas
hospitals will receive
500 cases of rem de severe
which has proven very effective enough
to treat
3200 patients in addition to the
cross-border spread
the stage of the pandemic is being
fueled by younger americans who
generally have little risk of being
seriously harmed by the disease
but can spread the disease we need all
americans to be conscious about their
actions and to exercise
extreme vigilance i trust all americans
to do the right thing but we strongly
advise everyone
to especially especially focus
on maintaining a social distance
maintaining
rigorous hygiene avoid large gatherings
and crowded indoor bars
and wear masks when appropriate we also
strongly urge citizens to take
extra precautions to shield those at
highest risk which are
in most cases in many cases the elderly
especially the
elderly with medical problems such as
heart
or diabetes but you want to shield them
and you want to guard them and you want
to protect them from the virus
especially
especially those that are really
targeted almost targeted you could say
by this horrible
horrible plague this horrible epidemic
pandemic
america will develop a vaccine very soon
and we will defeat the virus we will
have it delivered in record time
as our visit here demonstrates and i
want to thank all of the people and
representatives from the great state
of north carolina there's a great
there's a great place it's a phenomenal
place
and uh we've had so many great meetings
and
such a great time i want to drive and to
drive in tenacity of your
representatives and your politicians has
been incredible
when they call them there when they call
most of them many of them are sitting
here right now
i will always answer their call so thank
you very much i appreciate you being
here with us and
let's get on to a few questions
tremendous
progress has been made and it's been
made rapidly and it's been made in areas
that
nothing like that has taken place before
so please thank you very much
thank you thank you
there's been a lot of despair when it
comes to the virus is today's event
about giving americans uh hope
a sense of optimism is that what you're
trying to well i think
i think so but you know there would be
not that same kind of hope if we weren't
doing so well
where uh you know before just before i
left the white house in the oval office
we had a meeting with our
doctors scientists some others and
they're making tremendous
progress with respect to uh therapeutics
i can tell you therapeutically i think
over the next couple of weeks we'll have
some really very good things to say
uh we're just having great answers so it
is about that
and it's also the vaccine that we
discussed today at
even greater length is just coming along
really well and it's not just one
company as many companies have had
tremendous progress so that'll be
announced over the next very short
period
well i heard very positive things but by
the end of the year we think we're in
very good shape to be doing that by the
end of this year we're going to
in terms of the vaccine i think in terms
of therapeutics even sooner than that
therapeutics meaning you go and you give
somebody whether it's transfusion or
shots or whatever it may be
and they heal and they heal quickly so
we've had tremendous
progress we already have if you look at
rem disavir
and you look at some of the other things
but we'll have we'll have some
announcements on that over the next two
weeks yeah
it is hope but it's only hope because
we've gotten such incredible results
scientifically yeah you did talk with
russian president vladimir putin and i
wanted to ask
if you did bring up the reports of
russia having bounties on our soldiers
and afghans
we don't talk about what we discussed
but we had plenty of discussion
and i think it was very productive
larry kudlow earlier today said that the
v-shaped recovery is showing signs of
moderating
do you think given what we're seeing
with an increase in cases that the
recovery could be in jeopardy at all the
economic process i don't think so i
think the recovery has been very strong
we've set record job numbers we've set
record numbers whether it's a prv or a
little bit less than that
i think it's going to be very good if
therapeutically we
come up with some answers very quickly
which i think we will
then you're going to have a tremendous
recovery
likewise with the vaccines if you do
that by the end of the year that's ahead
of schedule substantially ahead of
schedule
and it's ahead of anything that's ever
taken place in terms of vaccines before
so i think if those things happen if
just one of those events happen
you'll go right back into that v and i
think you're probably in the v anyway
i really do believe a lot of the
governors should be
opening up states that they're not
opening
and we'll see what happens with them but
a lot will have to do with the fact that
therapeutically i think you're gonna
have some great answers vaccine-wise
likewise yeah please go ahead in the
back asking zachary aides from the
raleigh news and observer
um now that you've cancelled the
jacksonville portion of the rnc
do you think governor cooper made the
right choice in limiting attendance in
charlotte
well we're actually coming to north
carolina as you know
and we're having a very major i guess
that would be the nomination night so
that's
monday it'll be monday they're going to
be here and
the rest will do in a different form we
could have
done it many different ways but i think
we did the right thing and
i'm really happy that we're going to be
having a piece of it at least and a very
important piece
in north carolina yes please go ahead mr
president your
whole number suffered in recent months
because of your handling on the pandemic
you're
here now today what's your plan going
forward to prove to americans that
you're the right person
i think the poll numbers are very good
the poll numbers we have are very good
we're leading in north carolina
we're leading in pennsylvania we're
leading in arizona our numbers
we're leading in arizona we're leading
nicely in florida i think
our poll numbers are very good we're
leading substantially in georgia
i mean we get a lot of suppression polls
we get a lot of fake polls just like we
have fake news i mean it's a terrible
thing
when you look at it but i had the same
thing four years ago i was losing
everywhere i had poll numbers
i wasn't going to win any state and i
ended up winning every one of them
you know the swing states i wasn't going
to win any of them and i won all of them
and i have the same thing this year this
year they
have it even closer they have it closer
but it's the same
suppression type polls we have polls
that show me leading
in almost every swing state and
substantially
in other states by even more than a one
in 16.
when you look at florida as an example
you have thousands of boat out about
boats out of the ocean out on the
intercoastal
you look at other states where likewise
you have thousands of
boats and they're all waving the trump
sign
trump pence sign and they're so proud
thousands and thousands you've seen it
where you have bikers for trump with
lines that are miles long on highways
going along
on weekends i think there's more spirit
now
than there's ever been for my campaign
and that includes 2016 where obviously
there was great enthusiasm great spirit
we had great spirit
i think there's more today because what
we've done nobody's ever done before
nobody has ever rebuilt the military
cut taxes the most in our history
created the greatest economy we've ever
had
cut regulations at a level that nobody's
ever done
and all of these different things the va
we got va choice
we got uh va everything for
the va right now they had a 91 approval
rating
in a recent poll i was just speaking to
the secretary 91
in the via that's never happened before
uh i think when people see all that
we've done even space force
we created a force a actual
you know army navy air force marines
right it's
it's pretty amazing coast guard and now
space force that hasn't happened in 75
years
uh what we've done working with some of
those warriors over there by the way but
what we've done
has never been done if you look at
alaska with anwr
one of the bill perhaps the biggest
drilling site in the world
even ronald reagan and bush and clint
everybody wanted to get it done i got it
done anwar and alaska
probably or possibly the biggest
drilling site in the world
no what we've done has been incredible
recently it looked like the energy
business was going to be
a catastrophe we were number one in the
world and then we had the pandemic and
nobody was using energy nobody was
driving in automobiles
no gasoline and by the way gasoline
prices for everyone are very
very low in many cases less than two
dollars that's pretty
incredible and i saved the energy
business i got russia
and i got saudi arabia on the phone and
they cut way back
and we're now at dollars and plus
a barrel and we're saving tens of
millions of jobs and energy
we're the number one in energy in the
world so with all that we've done
we made and brought this country to the
greatest point in its history
we never had an economy like we had
prior to the china
plague or china virus coming in we never
had numbers like it
we are going to have them again and
everyone knows i'm going to rebuild it
i had to close it up we saved millions
of lives by closing it if we didn't
close it you would have seen numbers
that would have been
uh 15 times what you have right now one
death is too much
but it would have been 10 to 15 times
maybe more than that what you have
we close this greatest economy ever far
bigger than china better than china
china was having by the way the worst
year they had in 67 years tariffs
they paid us tens of billions of dollars
the worst year they've had think of it
in 67 years we were having the best year
we've ever had
i had to close it and now we're
reopening it and next year we'll be
stronger
it'll be the strongest year so far it'll
be better even than last year
okay thank you very much i'll be heading
back and i'll see you back at the white
house
thank you very much we're going to take
an additional tour
of the facility with your great leaders
thank you very much to the people of
north carolina we love being here thank
you